there are fewer types of 1.7 bug feed
they've been doing more serious
journalism recently but they will
forever be associated with the so goofy
you have to click headlines alike 13
potatoes will look like Channing Tatum
and of course you might be cleaning your
penis wrong by the way there is no wrong
way unless you're doing it in a sink of
the Chucky Cheese background right I get
it
though now TechCrunch is reporting the
site could go public as soon as next
year but there's a potential problem
both feeds millennial readers don't have
the money for big investments probably
because they work for sites like
BuzzFeed so if they want to succeed on
Wall Street they're going to have to
come up with headlines to appeal to rich
white gazillionaires comedians what some
clickbait BuzzFeed can use to reel in
the one-percenters Paula Tompkins 7
awesome man caves that used to be
national parks
[Laughter]
Kyle top 5 most exotic species to hunt
hit number three's just a homeless guy
alright buddy thanks Donna nine ways to
fire your nanny without making eye
contact all right point very good very
good
you